how you starting to turn the page all the
difficulties to day is the rather idea and
2 times vaccination still and buy it
nineteen is beginning across the european
union
the road sinus made available at the same
time to oils countries and people will
start hacking the often see  in evans in
room in helsinki
in sofia you just take it
a european vaccination they are touching
moment of unity and the european success
story very soon we will have no
see you often
because those a proven to be safe and
effective and the european union has
secure the  nato boxes or looking away
especially hal population of for 115
million people what he as a piece your
actions for neighbors
like iceland oh no way
maxim issue will help to get also know
me live bacon gradually once enough
people have been vaccinating
weekend city traveling meeting off and
his family can
and he took gal idea how the how long
for what until then we have to continue
to be careful
how you don't to protect our even and then
loved one  s van device
let's stay safe to better
let's make 2020 one a hier of european
recovery and hope